okay today we're going to do our session
on unsupervised methods so in particular
we'll look at principal components
k-means clustering and
hierarchical clustering
so these are all pretty straightforward
methods and we'll just demonstrate
on a simple example
so you get the gist of it
so
we're in our markdown again in our
studio
and here we have we're going to start
off with principal components
and we'll use the
data set that's in
in our called the usa arrests data
and
let's just have a look at it the dim
names we see there's a each row is a
state
and there's 50 states listed
and
each column is a
crime category so there's murder assault
and then we've also got urban population
percentage
and and rape
so
we're going to do principal components
of those
let's first just have a look at the data
we look at the means and the variances
of the variables
so the means are quite different
and and the variances are very different
now principal components is about
variance and so the mean shouldn't play
a role but the variances of the
individual variables will play a role
after all we're looking for linear
combination
that the largest principal component is
the linear combination that maximizes
the variance
and if you've got a single variable that
dominates with respective variants like
a saltier it'll pretty much eat up the
first principle component and so you
won't get anything meaningful out of the
data
and these variances are largely due to
the fact that there's different units
the measure each of the variables is
measured in different units
so all that's to say we're going to
standardize the variables before we do
principal components we standardize them
all to have unit variance
so pr comp will actually do that for you
if you set scale equals true and so here
we make a call to pr comp and assign the
result to pca.out
and then we can just print it as usual
and
and we see a summary
the standard deviations are actually the
standard deviations of the four
principal components there's four
variables so we can find four
uncorrelated principal components
and these standard deviations are always
decreasing
so you can see them the the largest 1.57
then it drops to 0.99 the smallest is
0.41
and then the what's called the rotation
are the loadings so the first principal
component
is
pretty much loaded equally on the three
crimes
and it's got a lower loading on urban
population so it seems like the first
principal component is just a measure of
how much crime there is it's just
essentially an average of the three
crimes
now notice the signs are all negative
well
the principal components are
don't care about sign because the
variance of a negative variable is the
same as if if you multiply it by -1 the
variance doesn't change
so we can easily just flip these signs
and we get the same principal component
just the science changed
and then you notice the second principal
component is more heavily loaded on
whether the the state has a higher urban
population or not
so it seems like the first two com
principal components so one is to do
with the total amount of crime the
others to do with the urban population
so
so that's what happens when we print
of course you can you can
do help on pr comp we're used to that by
now um and find out more about exactly
what it's giving you and what the
components on the object
but there's a very view useful way of
looking at principal components and
that's a biplot
and so here we do a biplot
and
we notice that the fonts are a little
bit
big so what i'm immediately going to do
is change a font here and make it a
little bit smaller i use that the cex
command and i'll make it 0.7
let's make it 0.6
and then we can see things a little bit
more clearly so it's made a plot of the
first two principal components
and so since the observations are the
states we see a position for each of the
states in this plot where the actual
name of the state is written out
and then in red we see
superimposed on this plot the directions
of the of the loadings
for the principal components himself the
the direction vectors
and so here we see that the
this first axis is largely due to the
the three types of crime murder assault
and rape
right
and so here's the one direction
so remember the component was negative
it had negative loadings
and so negative scores mean negative
times negative is positive so these are
the states in this end that have got
overall high crime so we see florida
over there nevada california
michigan new mexico
and in the other end of the scale are
those other states with with low total
crime so maine
north dakota new hampshire
um so this first axis is really to do
with the amount of crime in the state
and then the second axis we saw was
mostly loaded with
the loading was mostly urban population
and so this access is really about
whether the state is is has got a large
urban population or not
and
that also had a negative
loading so
new jersey has got a high urban
population
arkansas is on the lower side
mississippi north carolina much lower
okay so one plot and you get to see
you get to a nice summary of the
principal components so this is called a
biplot the word by mean in both the the
loadings and the and the the principal
component scores are put in one plot
okay
so principal components very popular i
encourage you to to to learn more about
them use them
and and
incorporate them in your data analysis